[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal préparé par les
équipes de tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 17
janvier voici les titres de cette
édition
suite à l'explosion du nombre de
contaminations et face à la forte
demande de dépistage le vaccinodromes de
saint quentin en yvelines ouvre dès
aujourd'hui une zone de test objectif
500 tests antigénique par jour
accessible sur rendez vous le point sur
l'opération dans cette édition la
nationale 10 bloqué ce matin attrape par
les acteurs du monde du cirque suite à
cette mobilisation contre l'interdiction
des animaux sauvages dont les cirques et
d'ici sept ans la préfecture a donné son
accord pour l'installation du cirque
zavatta ali de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines les essais du tram 13 sont
lancés objectif tester l'ensemble du
système de transport la future ligne
reliera saint cyr l'école à saint
germain en laye sa mise en service
devrait avoir lieu à l'été à 2022 et on
parlera également des circonscriptions
du département à suivre dans le cadre
des élections législatives et puis
l'entreprise biennoise air captifs
racheté par michelin et le lycée
hôtelier de guyancourt au coeur d'un
projet européen
[Musique]
il va pouvoir s'installer au mois de
février sur l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
le cirque zavatta douche et nicolas
zavatta douchez a obtenu une
autorisation allant dans ce sens une
décision rendue lors d'une réunion qui
faisait suite au blocage de la nationale
10 ce lundi 17 janvier à trappes par une
soixantaine de circassiens lé détail
dans ce reportage de nicolas d'andry et
laura légaux
il avait lancé le bras de fer ce matin
en bloquant la nationale 10 ils ont
finalement eu gain de cause après une
réunion avec le préfet des yvelines
le cirque nicolas zavatta douchez va
pouvoir s'installer au mois de février
sur l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines les dates seront définies dans
la semaine lors d'une rencontre avec les
responsables de la structure durant
cette rencontre à la préfecture les
acteurs du monde du cirque ont alerté
aussi sur les difficultés à exercer
leurs activités dans certaines communes
cette réunion une réponse à la
mobilisation d'une dizaine de cirque
lundi 17 janvier une soixantaine de
circassiens ont bloqué la nationale 10
dans les deux sens de circulation face à
la mairie de trappes leur message
continuer à exercer leur activité avec
des animaux c'est la liberté et du droit
du travail devant une mairie les
légalité et libertés cette manouche
alors plus aucun sens je sais quand on
rentre dans une mairie quand on dit
qu'on a des animaux c'est comme si on
était des voleurs ou des terroristes
alors que non justement on a des animaux
parce qu'on les aime si aujourd'hui
comme pour demain il ya plus d'animaux
dans les cirques excusez moi mais les
cirques il s'appelle cirque sans animaux
pour nous ce n'est pas des cirques il ya
d'autres formes de spectacles que j'ai
très bien mais le cirque traditionnel
doit continuer avec ces animaux si les
mairies font ça on sera obligé de
bloquer le monde du cirque doit faire
face aujourd'hui à la loi du 30 novembre
2000 21 visant à lutter contre la
maltraitance animale l'article 46 de
cette loi dispose sont interdits dans
les établissements itinérant la
détention le transport et les spectacles
incluant des espèces d'animaux non
domestiques
cette interdiction entre en vigueur à
l'expiration d'un délai de sept ans les
acteurs du cirque ont jusqu'en 2028 pour
faire face à cette transformation
suite à la suspension par le tribunal
administratif de versailles du précédent
arrêté concernant l'obligation du port
du masque dont le département le préfet
des yvelines vient de prendre un nouvel
arrêté et élevant à nouveau obligatoire
le port du masque donc dans le
département dans certaines circonstances
par exemple sur les marchés dans les
rassemblements aux abords des gares des
établissements scolaires ou encore être
des lieux de culte plus d'informations
sur le site de la préfecture la mesure
sera effective jusqu'au 20 mars 2022
passe à la circulation active de l'aco
vide et à la forte demande de dépistage
une zone de test anti génique a ouvert
ce matin ce lundi 17 janvier au
vaccinodromes de sky + 2 38 est ont été
commandé en urgence ils sont accessibles
uniquement sur rendez-vous avia d'octo
libre jusqu'à 500 tests seront donc
réalisés par jour de 9h à 15h le point
sur cette opération avec jean michel
fourgous le président du département de
50 ans le président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pardon au
micro de cilag à tsonga je me trouvais
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
une zone de test antigénique a été mise
en place depuis ce matin au coeur de son
maximum rom jean michel le faou rousseau
bonjour à vous êtes le président de
saint quentin en yvelines alors vous
avez pris la décision il ya quelques
jours de commander plus de 30000 et est
antinomique en urgence pourquoi parce
que les 12 maires on est douze communes
ici on vu la panique et dans les écoles
ainsi nos écoles en plus la vitesse de
contamination ont vu les queues devant
les pharmacies
et puis les organisations globalement
même occasion de la sortie française
parce que les gens dans les entreprises
ils sont appelés ils quittent leur poste
pour aller du bilan fin c est pour
tester ses il fallait plus en jouant
enfin voilà donc les douze ont pris la
décision d'utiliser donc de doubler le
côté vaccinaux d'hommes et de rajouter
le côté testo d'europe donc vous êtes
dans un vaccinaux testo drôle mais
j'imagine que c'est peut-être pour faire
face à la crise sanitaire actuelle est
de plus en plus de
personnes positives écoutez nous on voit
bien toute cette semaine je crois on va
passer on va dépasser les 400 milles
vaccination depuis le début après en
février parce que vers un demi million
donc bien sûr beaucoup de services se
sont ajoutés on nous a ajouté les
enfants nous rajouter les bons sens que
plus ya d'autres choses qui a et les
discussions pour les 6 12 ans les 5 12
ans les douze les 12 18 ans qui vont
devoir revoir leurs rappels se prépare
également une quatrième vaccination pour
l'ensemble bien sûr les français donc on
doit à chaque fois s'adapter et le test
o drom en fait partie on voit bien qu'il
ya une panique là dessus donc là on doit
on a fait ce gros centre et on ne
fêterait multiservices pour répondre à
cette crise qui est du jamais vu quand
même tout cas dans l'histoire de france
notre génération est alors concrètement
comment fait pour se faire tester ici
bas vous mettez sur d'octo libre comme
pour vous faire vacciner et on vous
donnait rendez vous assez rapidement
compte tenu qu'on à 30 milles
vaccination afin de 30 minutes est donc
on s'est procuré avec la rs comme notre
partenaire donc
donc ça se passe plutôt bien c'est un
système qui était de prouver maintenant
largement kfc preuve que les gens
commencent à connaître sa l'utiliser
donc ça nous facilite les choses bien
sûr et au niveau du cou tout le monde
peut venir se faire tester
c'est à dire que les plus jeunes
l'ensemble des personnes finalement de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et des
habitants cinq ans d'origine peuvent
venir c'est sur rendez vous comment ça
se passe les habitants et les gens qui
travaillent dans les entreprises de
saint gobain il n'ad'autre ci qui
viennent de ce combat il faut quand même
rester ouverts qu'on a un gros centre
est bon il n'est pas normal d'aider
au delà tout les yvelines ayant mais
c'est essentiellement centrée sur 50 aux
nations et donc les zones de test pour
compte bien qu'on reprenne sont séparés
de la zone de vaccination absolument
parce que ouais c'est pas c'est pas les
mêmes
personne c'est pas les mêmes objectifs
donc quand même bien sûr une plus isolé
le centre de testing que le centre de
vaccination pour une prise en charge
optimale j'imagine que vous avez
augmenté peut-être les effectifs de vos
personnels avaient à chaque fois celui
ci on a une forte réactivité parce que
depuis le départ plus d'un an on s'est
entraîné à voir des équipes qui peuvent
y sont assez élastiques ou ceop quand le
nombre de vaccins sont en baisse on
baisse le nombre de médecins et
d'infirmières et quand ça redémarre donc
on a une
une équipe assez assez éprouvée et s'est
formé et qui sait s'adapter et ça permet
et ses importations aux mules luc demain
on aura une autre information celle
d'aujourd'hui voyez-vous mais un grande
souplesse kelka de ski ce vélodrome nous
permet effectivement une très grande
souplesse face à ce fléau
de ce virus
justin portait sur la vaccination à
destination se poursuit comment ça se
passe sachant que donc il ya une zone de
test pour la vaccination aussi des
enfants vous en parliez tout à l'heure
de 5 à 11 ans comment ça se passe du
côté pour écouter ça se passe bien
cesser les enfants et une petite celle
de jeu qu'on leur ami
avec
mais sur un personnel spécialisé pour
les enfants
il ya aussi des pédiatres qui nous aider
maintenant plus parce que c'est vrai
qu'ils ont fait une façon de les
rassurer le moment encore encore que ça
se passe très bien on était un petit peu
on avait peur d'une même pas du tout là
la grande majorité les enfants
s'adaptent on en fait même un le jeu
puisqu'ils ont un diplôme après un jus
d'orange ils ont un petit questionnaire
ils ont non ils sont les sous qu'il ya
des médecins spécialisés qui sont qui
s'occupe d'eux donc non ça se passe bien
pour l'instant tout ça et bien sûr mais
ça demande des mains d'organisations
très important pour que pour bien sûr ça
se passe comme ça très bien et ben merci
beaucoup investi à force d'avoir été
notre invité
est toujours dans le cadre de la crise
sanitaire le pass vaccinale a été adopté
ce dimanche 16 janvier par le parlement
l'objectif inciter à la vaccination cela
signifie que pour accéder au bar au
restaurant ou encore au lieu de loisirs
tels que les théâtres les cinémas encore
les enceintes sportives vous devrez
justifier d'un pass vaccinale c'est
également le cas pour les transports
interrégionaux sauf pour motif impérieux
en revanche le pass and i ter est
maintenue pour l'accès aux hôpitaux et
les établissements de santé tels que les
cliniques où les ehpad concrètement un
test pcr ou antigénique négatif de moins
de 24 heures 20 n'est pas valable dans
le cadre du pass vaccinale pour
l'obtenir il vous faudra justifier soit
d'un schéma vaccinal complet soit d'un
certificat de rétablissement suite un
test positive à cauville 19 la loi
pourra entrer en application d'ici à la
fin de la semaine et elle concerne à
toutes les personnes âgées de 16 ans et
plus
[Musique]
vous l'avez peut-être aperçu ces
derniers jours le tramway 13 entre en
phase de test les premières rames ont
été livrées et commencent à circuler la
future ligne qui reliera à saint cyr
l'école à saint germain en laye en 30
minutes sera mise en service à l'été à
2022 les explications de mathilde de
franck où les premières rames du tram 13
commencent à circuler ile-de-france
mobilité et la sncf ont lancé les essais
dynamiques
si tout se passe comme prévu la mise en
service aura lieu à l'été 2022 l'idée
c'est vraiment de tester l'ensemble du
système de transport donc les voir sur
lesquelles circulent le tram l'arrivée
en station
l'alimentation électrique par la ligne
aérienne de contact
le système de freinage vous l'avez dit
et aussi à traverser surtout des
carrefours mais carrefour routier
traversées piétonnes que le tram soit
bien pris en compte à la traversée des
carrefours entre lisière pereire à saint
germain en laye et saint cyr l'école le
nouveau tramway empruntera des voies
déjà existantes qui ont été réhabilités
sur ces voies ferrées il pourra adopter
une vitesse plus importante entre on
peut rouler à 100 km/heure sur des voies
titre en classique avec la sinisation
tran classique avec toutes les
fonctionnalités du train classique
ensuite on un débranchement on sort de
la partie train pour rentrer en ville et
la duc on passe en mode tramway est là
du coup on a toutes les capacités
performance du tram au pur classique
pour circuler en ville de versailles à
saint germain les la future ligne
traversera des sites remarquables
le projet a dû alors s'adapter afin de
préserver au maximum le patrimoine
historique c'est un tram qui relie donc
le château de versailles et le château
de saint germain en laye et donc avec
des contraintes d'insertion dans le
patrimoine qui sont en forte et il ya eu
un travail qualitatif qui a été menée en
concertation avec l'ensemble des
architectes bâtiments de france des
monuments historiques l'inspecteur des
sites de versailles le tram 13 circulera
toutes les 10 minutes en heure de pointe
et toutes les 20 minutes en heure creuse
avec une capacité de 250 places dont 88
à 6 et le relire à saint cyr l'école à
saint germain en laye en 30 minutes
implantée à trappes l'entreprise erp
captif a été acquise par le géant du
pneumatique michelin en novembre dernier
la start-up créée en 2000 à 17 est
spécialisé dans la production de
structures gonflables en 2020 elle a
multiplié par quatre son chiffre
d'affaires et elle poursuit aujourd'hui
son évolution en s'appuyant donc sur un
grand groupe les détails dans ce
reportage de nicolas landry
elle est en hyper croissance après avoir
multiplié son chiffre d'affaires par
quatre entre 2019 et 2020 r captifs
vient d'être racheté par le groupe
michelin spécialisée dans la production
de structures gonflables cette start-up
devient une filiale à 100 % du géant du
pneumatique durant la crise coved en
fait les deux sociétés avaient commencé
à travailler ensemble en fait sur une
thématique de coussins gonflables à
usages médicaux lorsqu'emmanuel fievet
le fondateur de deir captifs c'est s'est
manifestée commettre comme étant
vendeurs de sa société de sa start up et
les pourparlers se sont engagés durant
l'année 2000 21 engagés dans les
secteurs de l'aéronautique de la défense
du nucléaire ou du médical r captiva
pouvoir bénéficier des capacités de
l'expérience de michelin objectif
structurer l'hypercroissance de cette
start-up d'une trentaine de salariés ça
va nous apporter plus de moyens humains
et financiers on a déjà vu pas mal de
personnes arrivées pour nous aider à
s'agrandir et puis à faire plus de
chiffre d'affaires et puis à gérer plus
facilement les les problèmes
du quotidien michelin a créé la société
visa mots qui était qui sont des voiles
dévoile gonflables et ont finalement
michelin n'a peut-être pas forcément
l'expérience dans ce domaine là dans le
domaine du gonflage à basse pression à
porter ça avec près de deux millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires réalisés
en 2021 air captive souhaite doubler ce
résultat en 2022 et devenir à terme le
leader européen des structures
gonflables
c'est le retour des dossiers de la
rédaction cette semaine il est consacré
aux circonscriptions yvelinoise à suivre
dans le cadre des élections législatives
à venir focus aujourd'hui sur la 5e
circonscription un duel sans doute
féminin elle même si les candidats ne
sont pas encore tous connus une
circonscription qui concerne à
maisons-laffitte sartrouville le vésinet
le mesnil le roi est monté sont les
républicains partent à leur reconquête
après la perte de la députation au
profit de yann brive est élu de la
république en marche les précisions de
mélanie poker' garder l'un des premiers
visages de la campagne législative dans
la 5e circonscription des yvelines est
connu conseillère municipale de
sartrouville vice-président de la région
ile-de-france et porte parole de valérie
pécresse dans sa campagne pour la
présidentielle
alexandra du blanche a été investi par
les républicains c'est une candidature
où je vais porter aussi ce projet pour
la france 2 valérie pécresse et dans un
territoire auquel je suis très attaché
puisque j'y vis mes enfants y sont nés
j'y suis effectivement adjointe au maire
de sartrouville j'ai le soutien des
maires de sartrouville de montesson du
mesnil-le-roi et de nombreux élus en
scrutin qui pourrait être 100% féminin
du moins pour le second tour pas encore
déclaré la deuxième candidate pourrait
être la députée sortante et président de
la commission des lois il ya une brune
privé l'élu la république en marche
préfère pour le moment se consacrer au
terrain et aux travaux parlementaires en
cours
oui le temps est venu de l'exercice de
mon mandat les français et
singulièrement les habitants des
yvelines ne comprendrait pas que je sois
en train déjà du monde positionné pour
le mandat suivant il souhaitait des
hommes et des femmes politiques c'est le
message qu'ils nous en riant 2017 qui
soit pleinement mobilisés sur le mandat
qu'on leur confie en 2017 ya une brawn
pie v et est élu et près de 59% des voix
elle remportait la 5e circonscription
face à jacques milliard alors investi
par les républicains le maire de maisons
laffitte s'est déclaré candidat en
novembre dernier
en octobre le parlement européen a
adopté de la ferme à la table sa
nouvelle stratégie pour une alimentation
plus saine équitable et respectueuse de
l'environnement et c'est dans ce cadre
que la maison de l'europe des yvelines
porte localement le projet europe à
table help organisé il ya quelques jours
à la visite d'une ferme à son chant avec
les élèves du lycée hôtelier de saint
quentin en yvelines reportage de grégory
canal et en collaboration avec mathis
godefroy de radio sensations
ils seront demain les ambassadeurs de la
bonne alimentation ses élèves du lycée
hôtelier de saint quentin en yvelines
visite ce jour là la ferme de la une
hier à son chant spécialisé notamment
dans l'élevage de volailles l'occasion
pour ces jeunes de découvrir le parcours
de la ferme à l'assiette ils se sont
rendus ensuite à l'atelier de
transformation valeur à gaz rang qui
permet à l'exploitant de vendre
directement ses produits c'est
intéressant parce que c'est beaucoup de
de produits qu'on travaille nous que ce
soit au lycée ou en stage et du coup pas
savoir d'où ça provient comment c'est
fait c'est important le cenou du coup
souvent on aller par exemple en termes
de poulets par exemple on a beaucoup les
poulets bas soit entier soit en
l'évidement sais pas vraiment comment
c'est fait comment s'est nourrie comment
ils s'en occupent toute l'année et c'est
donc c'est intéressant ça c'est toujours
très enrichissant de pouvoir partager
son expérience en tant qu'agriculteur et
encore plus avec des futurs engagés dans
la vie et dans la restauration parce que
c'est comme cela qu'on commence à faire
comprendre l'intérêt du travail de
proximité et de peut-être nous aider
futurs contacts visible dans le cadre du
projet e repas table porté par la
fédération française des maisons de
l'europe il s'inscrit directement dans
la stratégie européenne pour un système
alimentaire plus sain équitable et
respectueux de l'environnement repas
table vise à sensibiliser des actions
ont été menées auprès des lycéens du
corbusier à poissy par la maison de
l'europe des yvelines les élèves du
lycée hôtelier de saint quentin en
yvelines vont peut participer à un
concours projet fédéral sur toute la
france et qui va permettre à un binôme
de l'école hôtelière de participer à un
concours national en mars prochain à
louviers en normandie le binôme sera
sélectionné 10 6 février concours à face
à des participants venus de toute la
france les finalistes devront préparer
un repas pour six personnes en mettant
en valeur des produits normands tout en
y ajoutant une touche de gastronomies
européennes
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi dans un instant
vous trouvez michael elle me doit la
présentation de votre magazine sportif
avec bixente brillant santesteban pour
vos résultats du week-end très bonne sur
la hâte sur télé 78
[Musique]